hello there I'm here in Windsor to talk
to one half of a very famous couple who
spent the past 30 years at the Forefront
in the fight against AIDS
together David furnished and Sir Elton
John have raised hundreds of millions of
dollars to try to help end the epidemic
but their ambition to do so by the turn
of the next decade is under threat
across the world cases arising gay
rights are being repealed and the stigma
that has played the 1980s and 1990s
seems to be resurfacing so how much hope
is there of achieving that goal plus
what next for Sir Elton as his farewell
tour comes to a close including a
headline slot at Glastonbury this
weekend we'll be discussing all of this
on Beth Rigby interviews with David
varnish
[Music]
David thank you so much for talking to
us today and inviting us into your home
it's a real pleasure to be here and um
I'd really like to get on to the work
that you and your husband set out and
doing the issues you care about at the
moment but we do have to start if you're
indulging with Glastonbury of course
because sir Alton is headlining there on
Sunday it's his last ever UK show on
tour yes uh does the occasion make him
nervous or does he approach it as
another day in the office
um I think this one is very special and
so it is not just another day in the
office I think when he's in the middle
of his own tour and he's doing the
regular shows that he always does
um he's absolutely in the groove but I
think that's because it's a different
set list it's a huge outdoor Life
Festival he's got four different
collaborators joining him on stage at
different times who I will not name
sorry
so he's got a lot a lot of changes and a
lot on his plate so I think he's he's
anxious yeah but I think good anxious
healthy anxious so four collaborators
you're not going to tell me who they are
sorry I am sworn to secrecy yeah I know
and you'd have to you'd have to kill me
if you told me so that would be sad for
all of us
um
four big collaborators so it's going to
be a mega she's working for
collaborators of his choosing I mean
people he just thought I'd really like
to do something with these artists at
Glastonbury well we will be watching and
very we're very I'm very excited for it
um now now you and and so else have
devoid voted a great part of your lives
to the fight against AIDS
um and now antiviral drugs means that
people with HIV uh lead long and healthy
lives but back in the 80s and I I
remember this uh gay people face
terrible discrimination and for many gay
men AIDS was a real and terrifying
Prospect and progress has been hard won
when you look back David on that time
how scary and difficult were those days
for you
um it was terrifying because initially
there wasn't even a test to find out
whether you had AIDS or not gay men were
just dying these very horrible heavily
stigmatized deaths they were getting
fired from their jobs they were getting
abandoned by their families there were
Healthcare professionals who were
refusing to treat them
um and they were majorly stigmatized and
all alone
and the prospect of that was utterly
terrifying terrifying enough to keep me
in the closet for all of my twenties the
prospect of coming out and I was you
know dipping my toe in the water and
trying to come to terms with who I was
and the prospect of Dipping my toe into
that was utterly utterly terrifying
because even after they were able to
identify the virus there were still no
treatments
there was only palliative care there
were there was all sorts of horrible
language about this is God's retribution
for gay people living sinful lives and
to have all of that
piled on top of you when you're dealing
with an illness uh like AIDS where
people died very very long horrible
tortuous deaths it was awful I watched
so many friends waste away
and it was heartbreaking
um
it was a scary time I mean for young
younger people watching this for you to
say in my twenties I felt I could not
come out as a gay man because of the
stigma
that's that might surprise younger
people because it seems unconscionable
now that that would have been how a
young person would feel well there
weren't any role models
um in the world at that time I was a
student of business at University there
was nobody in business who was out uh
everybody was you know deeply in the
closet you had people like Boy George
and later on you know groups like
bronsky beat and Jimmy Somerville and
Frankie Goes to Hollywood who came along
um and that was fantastic but I I
couldn't relate to that that wasn't what
I was doing and when I tried to come out
to my mother when I was in my early 20s
she was scared for me she didn't reject
me she just thought what kind of Life
are you going to have you're never going
to be treated fairly you're never going
to get a fair shot in life because
you're going to go into you know an
everyday workplace and be discriminated
against
um and that was really daunting it's hit
the headlines in the 1980s in the west
and then the global crisis Focus Minds
at the start of the century
but do you fear now that people have
moved on from this thinking that it's no
longer a problem when actually it still
is I think there are some real
perceptual problems I think because of
the great success of the antiretroviral
drugs people are living long full
healthy lives symptom-free and side
effect free and so the horrible face of
AIDs that we saw you know 20 years ago
thankfully is gone but because of that
people are
not aware of it it's not as present in
everyday's lives people who are HIV
positive and taking their medication are
symptom free you couldn't tell if they
walked into him if you were sitting next
to them they're living full happy lives
and so it has fallen off the radar and
we are seeing growth in new infections
particularly in parts of the world
amongst young people because young
people didn't grow up with what I grew
up with and what I saw and they have no
sense that they are vulnerable as well
and as a result they're not taking the
steps and the precautions that they can
to protect themselves and David can you
give us the scale of the challenges we
sit here today
the scale of of HIV yeah the child yeah
the challenge was still fun well we're
dealing with marginalized communities
now we've kind of come back to where we
started uh in its in its sort of full
swing HIV AIDS was infecting 75 million
people globally about 37 million people
died
um so the rest are are living in our on
treatment there's a lot of undetected
HIV in the world there's certain groups
and key populations that we have
identified there's the
lgbtq plus Community there's people who
use drugs and there are young people
um and within those communities we are
seeing alarming rises in infections it
anywhere in the world
where we've seen the criminalization of
LGBT communities
um we see rises in HIV infection rates
because the whole disease itself becomes
stigmatized and people are therefore
scared to go and get an AIDS test if
you're living in a country where it's
criminalized to be gay you're not going
to go get an AIDS test and you're
certainly not going to go and pick up
your medication on a regular basis
because you don't want someone to think
you're gay you could get put in jail or
you could be recognized in a community
where you're going to be treated
shabbily and and Prejudiced against and
Dave if he puts it in that context to
some of the societal barriers in
different parts of the world
um you back the goal of ending the
epidemic by 2030 it's just seven years
away yes it's a it's a noble ambition
but is it realistic given the complex
the societal complexities your your
reference in well this is where we focus
on on the key communities the great
thing is we know where the problem lies
and the science is so good we have the
tools to affect the change that we need
to affect we can stop and create a world
with no new HIV infections we just need
the funds and the resources to get into
those communities and do the work that
we can do within the different groups
because we've proven that in other parts
of the world so you think you can do it
you see we do it and the unaids numbers
and the analysis are very very positive
it doesn't mean there will be an end to
AIDS completely but in terms of the
point where we Define it as an epidemic
the level of new infections we won't be
in that area anymore and that's a huge
result if you think about it I mean
we're going from a disease that arrived
in the 80s for which there was no hope
and within our lifetime we think we can
end it's quite I mean it's quite I mean
people remember make poverty history in
the 2000s that was a campaign for
countries to commit to increasing
foreign aid as a proportion of GDP in
the UK LED its way with that
we're kind of backing off
um
overseeds at the moment labor have no
commitment to putting it back up again
you're talking about
getting into marginalized communities
where they need access to health care
and support what's your message
to British politicians to other
politicians about the need to commit
resources
to help people in in less privileged
parts of the world well within Britain
I'm quite pleased with the British
government because we launched an
initiative called a social impact Bond
where we demonstrated to a cash-strapped
NHS that by finding undetected HIV on an
outpatient basis so by making people
that were having any blood work done on
an outpatient basis in a hospital we
said can we test you for HIV as well we
do this as routine we picked up so many
cases of undetected HIV in the three
boroughs in London in which we did it we
modeled the costs saved to the NHS and
it was in the tens of millions of pounds
so the government having seen these
results has given us an additional 20
million pounds to go into different
communities within England where I would
like the British government to step up
more is in terms of supporting the
problem globally we have the global fund
against AIDS TB and malaria which has
been a great success and at the moment
the British government has not yet made
its full commitment in the way that
other countries in the G7 have done and
so we're optimistic and hopeful in these
difficult times that we can continue
because this is the kind of work where
you can't take your foot off the
accelerator because people have to
continue to have access to these
medications and they have to continue
taking them in order for them to be
effective you have to take one pill a
day in most cases for the rest of your
life so consistency is very very
important in this fight and David can I
turn to Ukraine now can you remind your
remind our viewers about your history
visiting the country and your
experiences there well I mean we our
histories with the Ukraine is is
philanthropic and personal we have
supported the Ukraine because at one
point in time it had the largest HIV
infection rate of any country in Europe
and we partnered with some terrific
people within the Ukraine and have made
substantial inroads into dropping new
HIV infection rates in the Ukraine by 50
percent and aids-related deaths by 80
percent we've been doing that for the
last 20 years now well in the midst of
spending that time in the Ukraine out
and I were visiting an orphanage where
there were children who'd been orphaned
by HIV and very famously Alton picked up
that one little boy called Lev who
really
touched him and it was a lightning
strike moment and out and felt this
compelling overwhelming urge that he
wanted to be a father at that point and
Lev had a brother and we tried our very
best to get the boys out of the country
and in the end it was too complicated
and too difficult but we did find out
that they had a grandmother who was
younger and was alive and was able to
look after them
and she's done a wonderful job and we're
still in contact with them and they're
safe and they're out of Harm's Way which
is really wonderful but that started
a longing within us a desire within us
to have a family and adoption in this
country is very very difficult and very
complicated and can take years and years
and at that point out was in his 60s and
that was why we turned to surrogacy as
an option to have our two sons of our
own and so the Ukraine is very very uh
emotionally connected with our family
for many many reasons and how worried
are you about
the effect
the conflict with Russia the war in
Russia will have on tackling these
health issues in Ukraine that you have
worked so hard
to deal with as I mentioned earlier
access regular access to treatment is
important now we have a huge migrant
population people who are being you know
bombed out of their homes and traveling
across the country they're being cut off
from their health care providers and so
we've invested an additional one and a
half million pounds and put out 44
shelters mobile shelters so that we can
get people who are on the move and
continue to keep them on their
medication because someone doesn't stay
on their medication their viral load
drops down they become their HIV becomes
transmissible and they can get sick
again so the really important thing for
us and what we've continued to do in the
Ukraine is again maintain that
investment and hang on to those gains
that we've made and not lose them I have
to before we move I just have to say as
well Vladimir Putin is often hard about
warning about the dangers of extending
LGBT rights but then it emerges that
he's a great fan of Sir Elton that the
Russian Health Minister contacts sultan
to wish him a happy birthday do you find
it bizarre that a president that's
against LGBT rights should wish to
celebrate an icon of gay rights in the
way that he seems to celebrate but
believe me the iron the irony is not
lost not send me at all it's a it's a
real Paradox I mean interestingly
Putin if you ask him he's actually said
I'm not against gay people I'm about
protecting children and that's the
argument that a lot of people use for
putting these homophobic policies in
place that do damage communities and do
damage LGBT lives
um he professes to be a great fan he's
called out in a musical genius and says
he loves his music on the other hand he
puts this legislation in place and we
know with this legislation you know
again scared to get an AIDS test scared
to talk about it with other people
scared to pick up and access your
treatment we've also seen a huge rise in
violence against LGBT people adults
within Russia because of these laws
because it's constantly sending this
message that there's something wrong
that it's not right that it's sinful or
that it's dirty or that it's improper
and that
powers and impa it Powers hatred and it
empowers bigotry
um and it is so upsetting to see this
happening in different parts around the
world where we feel like we've made
gains and now you feel like you have to
step up absolutely and now advocate for
things that for battles that you thought
you had won yeah it feels like we're
losing some ground when I look at what's
happening in Florida uh Governor Ron
DeSantis has put similar bills in
schools in Florida which they say are
protecting children now they're talking
about extending the ages up to you know
all of school
um which I find such a horrible shame
because I really see what school has
done for my sons and it gives you a
foundation for tolerance and acceptance
within a skill school Community for my
sons their interaction within their
peers is the most important part of
their day and to be able to talk openly
and compassionately and appropriately
about you know the wonderful diverse
world that we live in to not have that
in the school environment is a massive
opportunity missed I think it's a real
real shame David you've referenced
um what Rhonda Santos the governor of
Florida in terms of this legislation
it's a parental rights Bill he's putting
through an education law it's been
dubbed the don't say gay Bill yes
the problem with the bill is that what
you can and can't say is not defined it
is left completely wide open also in the
bill is the ability for parents to sue
teachers to take legal action against
them if they think they have done
something inappropriate within the
classroom so with no guidelines and the
threat of legal action being taken
against you teachers in Florida are
terrified scared stiff that even the
simplest most appropriate discussion of
the diverse world that we live in an
lgbtq communities will end up with a
huge lawsuit on their desk and as a
result they're not talking about it at
all it's completely verboten how how
dangerous do you think he is I mean he's
a presidential candidate well I'm
horrified to see that he hasn't stopped
there he's now put laws in place in
Florida which allow a doctor to
discriminate against people based on
their beliefs which means a doctor can
refuse to treat somebody because they're
gay now I find that disgusting I find it
disgusting abhorrent and barbaric that
some someone can Empower a doctor
legally Empower a doctor to refuse care
to someone who needs it how
frightened are you that he could he all
Donald Trump could become the next U.S
president it's it's a terrifying
proposition because I my theory is that
America is so sharply divided
politically
and I don't believe the majority of
Americans
are extreme I don't believe it is an
extremist Nation Americans have been
incredibly kind and and and uh you know
supportive of us and our family but
there are these lapsed Fringe voters and
these extreme Fringe voters who sort of
come in and out and they unfortunately
can make the difference between making
and breaking an election with a country
that's so sharply divided where
literally the gap between the public
Republicans and Democrats is a sliver so
they're enacting these policies to bring
in these extra voters to get them over
the line that that's my theory
um and it's terrifying and
I hope
for a younger generation who have grown
up in a more tolerant world where there
were lots of role models and there have
been lots of people in the media in
business in music in films and
television that they
think of gay as being absolutely fine
and they don't have any issues with it
at all I hope that they go and express
their outrage at The Ballot Box what do
you say because some people watch it and
and Rhonda Santos would argue that he is
in tune with as he would put it ordinary
American families worry that their
children are learning about sex too
early about gender identities that they
dispute how would you respond
it's not argument I think he's making a
lot of massive generalizations and I
think he's missing a huge opportunity
which I talked about earlier which is to
build a foundation of Tolerance and
understanding in schools
um
what I think we do need is healthy
discussion with key partners and coming
up with appropriate guidelines so that
these discussions can take place in a
school environment but in an appropriate
way he's also introduced a ban on drug
treatments or medical interventions for
Trans people onto the age of 18 who may
want puberty blockers or surgery do you
what do you oppose that as well or do
you do you think it's too complicated I
find that the trans issue is extremely
complicated and it's very very personal
and it's very very much about the
individual
um
I don't like to see any Community
demonized I don't like to see any
Community marginalized or stigmatized
and I think again we need experts and we
need healthy discussions about what is
and what isn't appropriate within a
school environment for people of all
backgrounds one just one other thing on
this
um
here in the UK and I you might not want
to comment on this but here in the UK
there's also been a discussion about
women's rights versus trans rights with
you know JK Rowling being called
transphobic for raising those concerns
do you think that's unfair that she gets
targeted like that because she's raising
concerns about another kid or do you
feel it's communities being pitted
against each other than unnecessarily I
I like to see compassion and love for
all
um and I have tremendous admiration for
what JK has done with Harry Potter and
how she has made so many children
ReDiscover the joy of reading
um and and brought families together uh
in a way that no one has done for a very
very long time
um
I don't like to see any Community
singled out or stigmatized and I think
when you have a platform like she has
um
if I was in her shoes I would direct it
towards doing what I do best which is
bringing people together through my
through my work and through my art and
my culture okay so you think tight your
foot off the pedal in a way if I was in
her shoes yes
um I've only met her once I've never had
the conversation with her about it she
obviously feels quite strong about it I
don't agree I don't approve
um but that's not my my decision to make
I I just
Elton I know I live with someone as an
artist who every day sees his role and
his opportunity and his privilege is to
bring people together through his work
and through his art every time he goes
on stage and performs he sees as an
opportunity to
bring people together and not pull them
apart and so
um
I I would choose to just stay with that
okay
um just one other thing on DeSantis you
clearly think that if he became
president it's going to push LGBT rights
backwards quite dramatically in the U.S
absolutely absolutely he has he has
openly and outwardly campaigning saying
we are going to erase all left left-wing
social progress that has been made in
this country and he his wife is turning
up at rallies with a jacket saying
Warren woke on the back of it
um I think they've clearly laid that
those those battle lines down in the
ground and the prospective and being
present is utterly horrifying do you
feel like you have to become
in the Endeavors that you have made in
your life that you have to now engage in
this war and work that you have to now
speak up when you thought in a way that
these arguments have been won I do
because I want to live in an aids-free
world again back to doing what you do
best I've spent 30 years working in HIV
AIDS and when we start losing the
progress that we've made with human
rights and with civil rights rights
amongst communities who are deeply
affected by HIV AIDS I'm going to stand
up and fight because I have committed my
life as has album to ending this
epidemic can we believe we can can I ask
you one other thing about
um also something that's happened
recently that sir Alton commented on
which was the Philip Schofield situation
and uh sir Alton did an interview in the
rodeo times and he said it was an
example of the press being extremely
homophobic homophobic can you can you
explain to the viewer what he's getting
out there okay I
think without question
Phillip Schofield and Elton agrees
behaved inappropriately
and it could be perceived as an abusive
power and it was also he lied about it
so he behaved inappropriately I think
what was horrifying to watch was what I
would call a disproportionate
response within certain levels of the
media where it was written about over
and over and over where they were piling
on for days and then weeks continually
writing negative highly critical pieces
it felt disproportionate to the
situation at hand he did an interview he
acknowledged he'd made mistakes he wants
to go forward with his life this barrage
of negative media going on and on
certain parts of the media and I would
also like to add that those same
Publications didn't give the same level
of attention to a prime minister who
lied him as led to Parliament which to
me is a much much greater offense if you
weighed up the column inches that they
gave to Phillip Schofield and what
happened with this morning and what
happened with Boris Johnson recently you
know being banned from Parliament you'll
find a great great difference and that
to me points down so it's something so
actually although it's the the you're
acknowledging that there was a power
imbalance and that that was problematic
but what you're saying is it was because
it was two men and if it had been a
younger woman then it wouldn't
necessarily have been in in terms of the
response in the media yes okay I'm not
I'm not saying I want to be really clear
about this I'm not saying Philip
Schofield didn't do something wrong it
was a colossal error in judgment and
then he lied about it and he needed to
step aside and resign
um I think the media's response and only
certain parts of the media was so
disproportionately large and cruel and
personal that to me it felt like
homophobia because I don't think we
would have had the same response if it
had been between a man and a woman one
other thing on this is that and the
major has been the headlines on phone
hacking several cases gone through the
courts you yourself involved in one
Prince Harry another you've described
you and so Elton feeling very paternal
and protective towards uh Prince Harry
he received a lot of flack for taking
the stand he's had a difficult few years
how's he doing now he's fine Harry's
great he's I mean he's taken a lot of
flack in the media and you have to
remember he's taking on the media so
what actually happens in the courtroom
and what you read about in the newspaper
are often to very very different things
but we are in Fairly regular contacts
and he was very pleased the way things
went in court and he's doing really well
okay one well on that I'm going to go
back to where we began we've been
everywhere we've been everywhere in this
interview haven't we because it's the
end of the tour it says It's the final
and a big concert for him on this tour
in the UK
how will I've changed when he really
stops it just at home
or yeah he'll be doing what he always
does he'll be endlessly listening to new
music he'll be getting the charts
printed off and put in front of him
every day the US and the UK music charts
radio charts download charts and he'll
be going through with his highlighter
pen and looking at which records are
doing well and who's on the way up and
who's on the way down and which ones are
British uh which ones are new
um putting together content for his
Apple music radio show which he does
every week which highlights new talent
in the business he's going to go back
into the studio in October and start his
next hour oh wow which would be great
he's not done a studio album in a long
time we've got two musicals we're
opening next year we've taken Tammy Faye
which we opened at the Almeida we're
going to open that in a bigger theater
and then the Devil Wears Prada Okay so
we've been working on for 10 years so so
he's not chilling out was he you know
you're not taking it easy here no I
don't think he'll be sitting on the sofa
with the remote control unless there's a
football game on then that's the other
thing he'll absolutely be doing and he
and the boys sit down and they watch a
lot of sports together and I just I let
them get on with it it sounds like this
place sounds like a good place to hang
out it's a really good place to hang out
well look David enjoy Glastonbury I will
be looking out for you to see what
you're wearing
um thank you so much for joining us
today and thanks and thank you for our
message yeah thank you so much for for
having us at your home and being on our
show thank you thank you
well I hope you enjoyed this week's
conversation with David furnish as much
as I did
if you scan the QR code on your screen
right now you can listen to the Beth
Rigby interviews podcast each week I
take a look at the highlights of my
interview and there's some extra bits
and pieces in there too particularly
about politics that'll be on the Sky
News app or wherever you get your
podcasts that's all for this week from
Windsor thanks for watching
foreign